so it's up to both of us to make sure
this distance you know I don't s like go
okay so I'm I'm the boss you come to me
so the whole thing is M so we're here we
bow we do this and we work out a
distance and we adjust on that distance
we both adjust if the sensation the
feeling the sensing feels wrong then you
you adjust so where are there some
points here that we can improve on
so I come
here turn
the if I'm like this then I'm already
the the aggressor so we should both be
in a middle position
settled position I should about move
anywhere from this position I shouldn't
feel like there's too much way on the
front
foot I now bring it up over my head and
I cut him
straight he should be 10 cm or seven at
least through my wrist when he releases
I don't need to look down I just see it
out of my eye when he releases I lift
again and he comes up and has gives me
this feeling now if feels that he's
being pulled into it then he done an
action with the sword rather than an
action with his whole being so so by so
by the
wrist he releases it should be like a a
slight he should that's it he should
feel comfortable and I should be the one
to come back I watch
him and I see him there I I step this
way so I actually steep slightly around
the corner because that's where I saw
him going that then makes this better if
I don't step